okay welcome everyone um for the
assignments quantum seminar so today
we're happy to have you once ooh so you
want is a graduate student from
University of Maryland and he's done
lots of work in our area of quantum
simulation and so today he's gonna tell
us about some of the latest which is
joint work with his adviser under childs
and then Minh Truong made a rib and
Shushan zu nursery and he's gonna tell
us about the theory of other air so
welcome okay thank you very much for the
very nice introduction and today I would
like to say something about quantum
simulation and the title of this talk is
a theory of trotter error and this is
joint work which is done in
collaboration with Hendrick Al's Minh
Truong Nathan Webb and show Chandru so
to begin with let me talk about the
dynamics of quantum systems so as we all
know the dynamics of all quantum systems
are determined by its Hamiltonian it's a
hermitian operator according to the
so-called sharda equation so it's
basically a first order differential
equation with some initial condition in
general is this Hamiltonian is a
time-dependent operator then you won't
get a closed form solution for this
equation so in this case you just
formally represent the solution as this
is something called a time order the
evolution operators such as a formal
representation but in the special case
where this Hamiltonian is a time
independent operator then here we have a
very nice property we have a nice closed
form solution to this charting equation
is given by this e to the minus I th
it's just a matrix explanation so
basically it's a problem of quantum
simulation is as follows so you have a
Hamiltonian which is the time
independent case we have an operator
here we have a evolution time as a time
T and basis
the problem is you just want to perform
this e to the minus i th apt with some
error absolute so this problem seems to
be very straightforward basically you
just want rates banana the matrix but is
actually quite difficult for a classical
computer when the dimensionality is
large but on the other hand the solution
of this problem could potentially be
applied to many errors the for example
how people have been trying to explore
the application of quantum simulation to
studying chemical reactions or studying
material science and also there are also
applications of quantum simulation to
these any other quantum algorithms for
example if you have an adiabatic
evolution you try to implement that on a
quantum computer using ideas of quantum
simulation and also in more recent years
there have been many algorithms proposed
for something other problems such as
solving linear equations or some other
problems and in those algorithms some
love meanings of many of those
algorithms to use quantum simulation as
a 17 and you know in fact is quantum
simulation is actually one of the your
internal motivations for five months who
proposed this idea of a quantum computer
and nowadays people like to talk about
nearby vacations and quantum simulation
is also one of the potential problem for
near-term quantum computer to solve okay
so there are making algorithms that you
can use to simulate Hamiltonians on a
quantum computer but perhaps the most
straightforward approach is this
approach based on product for members
so I guess depending on who you are
talking with you could get different
names for the same matter so for example
there are some people working in physics
usually call it a quarter addition but
they say they have an evolution then
they want to authorize an evolution well
on the other hand you are also people
working on mathematics
usually for example numerical analysis
would require the splitting method or
operator splitting lesser but you know I
don't belong to
two groups so I'll just call it product
for dinner in any case the Assumption
here is that we have a target system
which is given as a linear combination
of terms so basically you have a
Hamiltonian which is given as a sum of
several terms and you assume that each
term is a hermitian operator and can be
exponential with constant cost on a
column so end of this assumption what
you can do is use this so kind of first
ordered each other forever so instead of
remember that your goal is to exponent
we can introduce need question when you
meet by can be exponentiated with cost
of one or there's more general yes so
basically this Hamiltonian is decomposed
into several terms and you assume that
the the operator each is a minus I theta
H gamma can be decomposed into
elementary quantum gates and the number
of case that used you know decomposition
is constant and it can be computed in
constant time also the decomposition the
coefficients are can be computed okay so
basically the case complexity of
implementing each each of the H gamma is
constant for example it could be two
local powder terms like X s Y 1zz
something like that does it make sense
yeah thanks but any case the remember to
cohere is that you want to exponentiate
the sum of this these operators but what
you can do is you individually
exponentiating each operator and then
you put them together so this is
sometimes called a first order the
Charter formular because it's first
order accurate so the error will be
second order in the time which required
a quarter error and your elimination you
have to control the error and to control
this error it turns out that you don't
directly applied this formula to the
entire evolution but rather what you
want to do is you first divide the
evolution into our steps called Trotter
steps and then within each step you
apply this above formula and then you
put them together repeat our times so in
order to control the error what you can
do is you truces are to be very large
sufficiently large so that your total
arrow be controlled below absolute so
this will give you a product format or
algorithm you can analyze the gate
complexity as the number of steps times
the number of operators that you perform
within each step ok so this is a simply
store formula that you can use there are
also some more complicated formulas that
can help you achieve higher order
accuracy the for example in general you
could have a piece order product formula
so I'm writing some expression axis so
in general you could have multiple
stages in the product further and then
within each stage you could have
different orderings of the Hamiltonian
terms and this could help you achieve
higher order cuts so this expression
seems little bit complicated but I can
give you a very simple example so
there's some well-known construction by
Suzuki in 1992 his construction he
started with a second order 4 meter so
if you look at this definition you'll
find that it's a symmetrized version of
the first auto formula right so you have
two such stages in the first stage you
order the term in the forward direction
and in the second stage you order the
term in the backward direction so this
satisfies the above general form and
then you can construct them more
higher-order formulas based on this
Suzuki ads - okay for me okay so in any
case these are some very simple
mathematical tools that you can use to
simulate hamiltonians on a quantum
computer I should mention that the
ancestors
approach there have been many other
approaches developed in recent years for
a quantum simulation so you know here I
have a picture we show some of the other
quantum simulations it's a picture
discovered by Michaels army so if you
look at this picture you see that
there's this algorithm based on
truncating Taylor series there's this
other algorithm called the qubit ization
there are also some other articles in
for example the scalpers and based on
quantum walk and many many other quantum
simulation algorithms so you know
product rahmanir doesn't look very happy
because this more recent quantum
simulation algorithm have improved
asymptotic performance as a function of
the evolution time and the accuracy over
the the basic product formula approach
so I guess maybe some people want to say
let's just forget about protocol for
members because you know we have this
more advanced than fancy or quantum
simulation algorithms but perhaps it's
not the right thing to do because if you
actually look at the empirical
performance of these quantum simulation
algorithms actually in many cases
product vomiter can become the best one
to use so here I have a picture where I
compared the gate complexity of
different quantum simulation algorithms
for simulating a one dimensional
Heisenberg so it's a nearest neighbor
interactive system and then I compared
the gate complexity as a function of the
of the system size so you see from this
picture that indeed if you only care
about the rigorous error analysis and
production order doesn't perform really
well well it has the largest decayed
complexity among all the other quantum
simulation algorithms but on the other
hand if you story and all the empirical
data into this picture there's a huge
change so now really product vomiter has
at least a gate count among all the
quantum simulation was bigger so there
is a significant gap between what we can
prove for the product from there and
what their actual performance so
you know this is something that we need
to try to further understand what is
going on here so beyond this reason
there have been many other reasons why
we need to continue to study product
formers also it has been somehow
de-emphasized in britain theoretical
studies of quantum simulation so
producto memory is some very simple
algorithm doesn't use any other qubits
to do that the conversation which is
perhaps more suitable for near-term
quantum simulation but on the other hand
as we just saw in that picture product
from universe can sometimes be very
efficient especially in the case where
many in terms of the Hamiltonian
commutes or nearly doubles so this is a
unique feature that doesn't seem to hold
for like more general more reason
quantum simulation algorithms well there
are some additional features so for
example product formula is a direct
translation of the terms of the
Hamiltonian it was correspond
explanation so thompson's this kind of
translation can preserve certain
properties of the system for example if
your system is nearest neighbor
interacted something like this you have
red blue red red blue something exists
the corresponding e you can try to
construct a quantum circuits according
to product formulas and you know you
have this this picture also has some
locality property and sometimes this can
help you to further speed up your
simulation other applications for
example in classical simulation of
quantum systems quantum Monte Carlo
simulation and also in sometimes in
areas beyond quantity so basically there
are many aspects of product formers at
work I explore but in this work we would
like to focus on the second point
let's do here namely we want to
understand how product farmers can
exploit the commutativity of a
Hamiltonian to speed up conservation
okay so there are some previous work on
trying to understanding this capability
and I guess I can
tell you some of the previous attempts
to understanding this capability so
there's something called a baker can
bear how stuff expansion so let's say
suppose we are we have a very special
example where this Hamiltonian only
contains two terms like we only have a
and B two term Hamiltonian then there is
a representation of the Charter error as
something exists so here you have the
ideal evolution it's each of the a plus
B but then you also have some error term
and this paper can bear a host of
expansion and helps you represent the
error of the exponent represented as a
infinite series okay so I guess I'm a
little bit sloppy here because I didn't
tell you about the convergence of this
series but for now let's just ignore
this issue and assume that this BCH
expansion always holds then basically
you can just represent this error as an
SJ commutator if in a series okay so
there are several things that we can do
about this BCH expansion so for example
one thing that we can do is we can say
let's ignore all the higher-order errors
there's only look at the focus on the
lowest order error as it is T Square and
commutator of BNA and we try to
understand the the scaling of this term
well this approach is very intuitive
because it tells you the commutation
information of the Hamiltonian I think
the error analysis but it's not very
rigorous because it turns out that in
many cases those higher-order error
terms in this expansion actually
dominates the error contribution so if
you only look at the lowest order error
sometimes you even or the significant
contribution from the higher order terms
so another thing that you can do is you
say let's try to tear up some tables so
for example whenever you encounter this
commutator of B and a you always upper
bound the norm of this by
times norm of B times the norm of a so
from there you try to divert some tables
well this approach is very simple to
calculate we can try to calculate a
number out of that but it doesn't
explore other commutativity of the
Hamiltonian it's throw away that
information so it doesn't provide a very
tight bound in general another thing
that you can do is you say for some
concrete systems let's try to directly
calculate this infinite series
well that approach turn out to be very
advantageous for systems with some me
outrigger structures but for other
systems we won't get a very tight bond
in general okay so it turns out that
none of this analysis will give you a
very tight analysis in general so this
is something that hasn't been answered
in previous work but if you only look at
a low order program from the road like
say the first order formula then
actually you can get a very tight
analysis so let's say suppose we want to
look at a first order falling through
again we have a two-term hamiltonian h
equals to a plus b and then we have this
first order formula which is e to the a
e to the B and for this first order
formula in this special case you can get
a very tight bound so how do we do that
well you start with this differential
equation so you differentiate this first
order formula and you try to write down
this first order differential equation
with some initial condition it has not
that the solution of this differential
equation is given by something called a
variation of parameters for me so
basically applying that formula you can
get an integral representation of the
error of the first order for it okay so
inside this integral you have a lot of
matrix explanations they are not very
important for us because
when you calculate the spectral norm
they will be evaluated to what because
there are unitary operators so the thing
that we should focus on is this thing in
the middle its coloring Orange and for
this term we can further get another
integral representation by doing
something like fundamental theorem of
calculus to get another integral
representation but differentiate this
term okay so let's now put them together
we have a double integral representation
of the error of the first order formula
and as we just mentioned there are a lot
of Exponential's here but they're not
very important because we can just
evaluate the spectral norm to one so the
important thing is a commutator in the
middle and we just keep it our error
bounds okay so this error bounds turn
out to be pretty tight because if you
compare this expression with the
previous bch formula you see that it
exactly matches the lowest order term of
the BCH expansion and now the idea is
that we can trigger as we prove this for
the first order from it okay so this is
a special case to term Hamiltonian well
you can try to generalize this to a
general Hamiltonian by bootstrapping
this kind of analysis and you can try to
derive a similar error bounds for the
second order formula but unfortunately
before this work there have been no
generalizations to arbitrate higher
order formulas using commentators of
that okay so instead we derived the
following results network called a
shorter arrow with commutator scale so
let's say we have a product formula
let's say we have a piece order product
folder and we try to simulate this
Hamiltonian given as a sum of operators
they claim that the error of this
product vomiter will skill exist
depending on this quantity called
of a computer so what is alpha computer
well it's given as the sum of all the
possible nasty commentaries of the
hamiltonian with key layers so this is
arguments about the error of the product
that's a shorter error but you can
directly translate that to an argument
about the gauge compact I won't show you
how you do the translation but it turns
out that the resulting gate capacity
also depends on this quantity called
alpha computer so you know this is a
quantity that we need to try to compute
if we want to compute the complexity of
product form well our beers needs is
expression symmetric so if you only care
about a simple scaling then you don't
have to worry about the order of the
terms because all of them will give you
the same of a computer but of course if
you care about the constant prefactor
then you have to choose your ordering
carefully this is a bound for the
additive error for the real time
evolution and there are also some
related bounds for multiplicative error
and imagery time evolution and I didn't
show you in this presentation I guess in
the following I can probably present
some of the applications of this main
recessed who each attack on of
simulation quantum Monte Carlo
simulation but before that maybe I can
stop for a few minutes to see if there's
any questions
one question is so these are all big O's
so is there can you argue about these
bounds being optimal in some sense this
is the power of T probably this is easy
but but then yeah I guess some yeah
that's a very good question so I guess
Carly we don't have a very good lower
bound arguments but for very simple case
like this first order formula you get an
arab on like this and it turns out that
sis will measure the visa sh no other
term of the psh expansion so it's pretty
tight in this sense but for general we
don't have a good lower bound argument
for this so I have a question which is
you said that before for the high order
commented about it was not in the
literature I think maybe there are but
in the standard applying that numeric
analysis literature you early the
commentator bound is not like end
product then product is further to bound
the committed applies to the solutions
person to buy some high or the
derivative norms of the solution so it's
not reasoning that way but I think there
are some works thanks for the comments
oh there's a let me read one question oh
so you on everything here was time
independent so is there any way in which
some of these things generalized to the
time dependent case yes that's a good
question so I think I think this
analysis will be able to generalize to
time-dependent case but we didn't work
out the details in the paper but I think
it should be generalized oh here's
another question along the lines of a
previous question which remark that the
bounds have been worked out for the end
product I imagine you'll also go ahead
and show some of your explicit speedups
for some of the specialized hamiltonians
but i was wondering if there's a greater
pattern that you can see to them like
what are ingredients for a hamiltonian
such that you won't be able to do much
better than these bounds and how in
general can you for tell how well a
hamiltonian might do I see so I guess
some perhaps um a general motive that we
considered as applications of this
result is so called the K tokoha me Tony
so your hammie tony is written as a sum
of several terms and each term acts on a
constant number of qubits and i think
this model is it's a very general model
that includes many more specific
concrete systems and we are able to show
there is a speed of using product
commoners for simulating Conoco
Hamiltonians and i don't know i guess
probably this could give some intuition
song the kind of ideas going on behind
the speaker
that the hell's your question yes I
think in part I I might be asking the
question too early because I imagine
you'll be speaking about this later in a
talk but but the last question two
questions ago made me think about what
other classes of Hamiltonians might lead
to a speed-up and those other estimates
that were given for the end product
might give some hints I never thought of
looking into literature for those kinds
of calculations for example is it the
Hamiltonian might not be key local it
might have some tensor network structure
or it might have some tree structure and
yeah you know you mentioned chemistry
and molecules definitely have more
structure than just being K local yeah
exactly yeah thanks I think that will be
a very interesting question to explore
for future work on try to apply some of
the analysis here to understand the
performance of product founders for
simulating other systems
okay so I guess maybe I'll continue I'll
talk about some applications that we
found in our work to digital atom
simulation quantum Monte Carlo
simulation okay so a first example is a
simulation of nearest neighbor lattice
system so I guess in the simplistic case
we have this one the nearest neighbor
system I say we have a me Tony which is
decomposes in minus 1 terms or in terms
and we only have nearest neighbor
interactions this kind of systems are
able to model many important physical
systems in condensed matter physics
nuclear physics and quantum theory and
it has been studied in different context
by previous work so for example there's
a previous work by Jordan the Empress Q
studying this kind of system in the
context of confuse your simulation so to
say they claim that you can actually use
product foreigners to simulating to
simulate this kind of nearest neighbor
lattice Hamiltonians with a complexity
that is very close to ontology so we're
any size of the system and teasy
evolution times it's basically a
complexity very close to industry so the
matrix claimed in the paper but it even
gives rigorous justification and what we
can do is we can apply our new results
to give a rigorous justification of this
claim so remember that to understand
product vomiter we have to compute this
quantity called alpha computer well it's
given by this sum of nasty communicators
what we can do is we can start with the
innermost layer of this operator we
start with this H gamma well for this
operator you have n minus 1 choices or n
choices can be arbitrary Hamiltonian
term but after fixing one term in this
Hamiltonian and we asked how many number
of terms don't commute with this one
well there are only constant numbers
because we are looking at the nearest
neighbor system maybe at most 2 and we
have the same question for the third
operator so we say how many number of
terms don't community in there most or
two operators well there are also
constant number of them so we can apply
this arguments to all the operators in
this expression and as well as the order
of the product from there's constant we
can always have constant number of
choices here and there are only
independence for the innermost layer
operator
so overall the this alpha computer is
bounded by its power of M it has a
linear scaling in terms of the system
size okay so now we can basically plug
this with us into the main theorem of
this paper and we can correspond
anything rather giraffes destroyed on
the Empress kill chain about the gauge
compact Studios
simulating this nearest neighbor logic
system
okay so this is a simulation of
nearest-neighbor lattice system my
second example is a simulation of
electronic structure Hamiltonian
so in this case so Hamiltonian looks a
little bit complicated but at a high
level its decomposed as the sum of a
kinetic term plus two potential terms
and here I'm considering the second
quantized the plane wave electronic
structure so this kind of system
efficient solution of the simulation
problem could be helpful in the designer
and engineer of catalysts and materials
so people have been trying to consider
the simulation of such a high metallic
well let's say if you have a ends being
orbitals and you want to evolve the
system for time T then the best our
previous algorithm for simulating this
system is an algorithm called
interaction picture algorithm developed
by Lo and width so this algorithm is
asymptotically speaking very fast but
unfortunately people don't quite
understand the practical performance of
this effort very complicated algorithm
and so now we can ask what happens to
product from this well if we want to
analyze the product founders remember
that we have to explanation each term
from the Hamiltonian well for the
potential terms written down here that's
not very difficult because you know
these are the so-called number operators
they all commute with each other
so you can directly exponentiate those
terms but for the kinetic term there's
some some issue here because in general
like this second quantize the operators
won't commute with each other but
there's a trick that you can use here
because also we are summing two indices
J and K here the coefficients will only
depends on the difference of KMJ right
so you have K minus J here whereas you
are summing over two illnesses so
basically your coefficient matrix is a
translation invariant matrix and in
terms of that it can be done
bifur a transform in this case we are
using the fermionic fourier transform
it's basically if your appliances from
Miele free transform you can diagonalize
the connected term into this
diagonalized from how you implement use
product form okay so now the question is
what will be the gate complexity of this
algorithm well again this try to turn to
this alpha computer well by using some
standard rules of second quantized
operators commutation relations we can
estimate the size of this alpha computer
to be entered to the p plus 1 and if you
further plug this results into the main
theorem and you get a gate complexity of
the product from their cousin which is
like N squared hams T very closed with
that nearly mentions that interaction
picture happens so in the special case
of second-order 4 meters this confirms a
written numerical study by some lots of
people from Google's group and other
groups ok so this is a second example
the third example we have been looking
at is this example of simulating
canonical Hamiltonians so in this case
you have Hamiltonian given as sum of
operators and each operator only acts on
k keeo case constant so this kind of
systems appears in in the study of many
many errors of physics and the best our
previous algorithm to simulating this
kind of kadokawa me Tony it's an
algorithm called a qubit has it really
develop at low Antron so basically if
you apply this qubit hesitation
algorithm you'll find that the gate
complexity of the simulation will
depends on this quantity called the one
norm of the happy zone I won't be able
to explain why we have this dependence
but basically we have to go through all
the terms in the Hamiltonian and for
that you have a complexity dependence
that depends on the sum of the size of
those terms
so we have this one norm defendants of
Hector well again a question that we ask
is what happens to product fathers well
again we have to look at this quantity
called alpha computer is given by sin SG
/ mediators and if you use some locality
property to simplify this nest economy
Victor you get this expression
so it's instance a one norm we have
already seen that but we have this new
quantity this three particle lie norm
I'll call it induced one norm so this
induced one norm is defined as this
quantity where you fix Y index si el
that's alt index and you are summing
over all the remaining indices so this
is something we define as induced 1 norm
okay so now you plug this results into
the main theorem you try to figure out
the gate contacts you have for that
formulas and you find that the resulting
algorithm will scale according to you
almost or according to this induced 1
norm and each other that is induce one
norm is always smaller than the one norm
and sometimes this gap can be
significant for some systems so in this
case we can hope to actually use product
founders to do a faster quantum
simulation
okay so my next example is the
simulation of rapidly decay and
power-law interactions so you have a
Hamiltonian given as a sum of several
terms and you assume that the size of
those terms well UK according to some
power law they say well over the
distance to the power of alpha so
examples of such systems include the
dipole-dipole interactions and van der
Waals interactions and there also some
previous studies of simulating such a
system for example the past our previous
algorithm for simulating this kind of
power law Hamiltonian is an algorithm
inspired by the Robinson bounce so there
are some localities that you can use to
simulate this closed system so again the
question is what can we say about
product formulas well since we have some
locality here like the interaction
strength of this Hamiltonian decays
really very fast we can actually do
something clever so we can first do a
truncation of this Hamiltonian we throw
away all the terms with very little size
and it turns out that we if we choose a
cutoff to be something like this then it
will be very good for the parallel
Hamiltonian and for the truncated
Hamiltonian which is again compute this
quantity of a computer and after some
careful calculation you can see that the
skating of this alpha come to you there
will be something like oh of n so
plugging this result into the main
theorem of our work we can get a product
from an airport with the skating that is
something like this so if you compare
this skating with the best of previous
algorithm you see that the factor 2 in
the exponent is now improved to 1 so we
saw his improvements you can hope to
again use product formulas to do a
faster cotton simulation
okay so my next example is a simulation
of clustered homogeneous in this case
you have an N cubed Hamiltonian and you
try to group
different qubits into different parties
you have strong interactions within each
party and you have weak interactions
between different parties so there's a
previous study of such a Hamiltonian
down by pong Hara also zoo so to give a
hybrid classical quantum simulator from
simulating such a system so in the
construction of the simulator to use
product formula as a subroutine and we
are able to apply our new results to
improve the performance of the simulator
okay so my last example is the
simulation of transverse field Ising
model and one fair magnets so actually
here is a knod quantum simulation
anymore it's quantum Monte Carlo
simulation it's a classical simulation
so the goal here is you try to
approximate the partition function
having some multiplicative error so
there are some previous results by
Praveen concepts does it consider
simulating the transverse field I Simona
and quantum fair magnets and their
algorithm use product formulas as a
subroutine and again we are able to
apply on your results to improve the
performance of the simulator
you know also it's a student as a
practical algorithm
it's absolutely improvements okay so we
have been talking about attractive
making the evolution of a quantum system
and if your goal is not to simulate the
food and Alex but we were also try to
approximate the results on the low carbs
or bone then you can get a further
speed-up
so we show that you can actually use
product formulas to simulate the local
absorbance
with a complexity that is independent of
the system size for parallel
interactions and as a by-product we
obtain deep Robinson pounds nearly
magical recent bounce okay so we have
been talking about asymptotic skating
but you can ask what will bother the
constant pre factor of
of this bounce so what we have done is
we have redone some of the numerical
simulations of the previous
one-dimensional Heisenberg model and our
new results are illustrated by these
green squares and we find that this new
data indeed improves over the previous
best data and it also seems to be pretty
tight it only loses by a factor of 5
compared with the empirical performance
so turns out that the result of this
analysis would also gives you a pretty
tight error bound in practice ok so we
can make a very brief summary basically
we try to understand some of the
mathematical mechanisms behind this
product for other approach and try to
identify some applications of this
mechanism to simulate in quantum systems
so specifically to the simulation of
nearest neighbor lattice system
justifying the previous jar and the
Empress cocaine to the simulation of
electronic structure Hamiltonians
nearly matching the interaction picture
algorithm to the simulation of general K
doko hamiltonians outperforming the
qubit ization approach to the simulation
of rapidly decaying parallel
interactions faster than the vibra
robinson based approach we have some
improved results for simulation kratzert
Hamiltonians in quantum Monte Carlo
simulations and also some neuroses for
simulating local service so each other
that underlying all these improvements
in some some mathematic rules that we
developed for analyzing trata error I
guess I still have a few minutes so
maybe I'll very briefly
sex so very briefly talk about some of
the underlying ideas is not too
difficult to understand so so the first
component is try to understand the
different types of the error so let's
say we start with a product for Miller
and we try to simulate this Hamiltonian
for some time
well it turns out that you can have
different types of there for example
let's say you you can have an error that
is additive to your I do evolution so
that's this I do evolution plus
Americans well you can put the error in
the exponent of the time ordered
exponential so you have this operator
itaú which means as a time out or the
operator well you can also have
multiplicative error exists so yes I do
evolution times this error average each
other that you know these three types of
trade era are equivalent to each other
where you talk about quantum simulation
but for other applications such as
quantum Monte Carlo simulation remember
that your goal is to try to approximate
the potential function up to some
allocated for error so probably in that
case you might want to use this certain
third type of this analysis but in any
case the the good thing here is that all
the three operators will have a very
common structure it's there were always
consists of unique unitary congregations
something like this do you have some
operator in the middle and then you have
unitary congregations on both sides so
later when we discuss representation of
this trotter arrow will be able to
analyze discuss how we analyze the
unitary conjugation of such an operator
okay so this is airtight so the second
component is order conditions so by
definition the product formula will
satisfy some order condition let's say
if you have a piece order for that
kilometer you approximate the idea
evolution to keep order accuracy so you
had some auto condition here well
equivalently you have some other other
conditions for the additive error and so
why we care about other conditions well
it turns out you can use other
conditions to cancel terms so
specifically you have a piece order
condition you can argue with some single
arguments so slow other terms in the
Taylor expansion won't have here so it's
basically zero operator okay so now that
we have some error types and other
conditions we can try to represent the
trader error so remember that in the
Trotter arrow the common structure is
this kind of unitary contribution so you
have some operator in the middle and you
have unitary operations on both sides so
we basically try to understand how to
represent this expression well it turns
out that this expression has a following
kind of expansion so you have finite
number of terms in the front and you
have some remainder terms here so terms
in the front they are time independent
operators so basically you can apply
order conditions to cancel those terms
so they won't appear in your final
representation well for the remainder
terms what you can do is you derive the
following representation so there are a
lot of Exponential's inside this
representation but they are not very
important because their spectral norm is
one so and just ignore them and the
important thing is a middle thing where
you have a nested commutator and that is
thing that will be preserved in the
final error bound which you will give
you a commutator bound in general which
seems to be very tight okay so perhaps I
could say something about possible
directions for future work I guess
somebody already mentioned this
time-dependent Hamiltonian simulation
case this problem could have additional
applications for example in developing
quantum control schemes describing
quantum chemical reactions and
implementing a diversity of illusions
and of course a problem becomes more
complicated to solve and it'll be
interesting to try to understand whether
the analysis could be applicable and
written the easier have been many
generalized
for not foreigners developed for example
that there are constructions based on
divide and conquer idea based on
randomized a construction and linear
combination of unitary construction and
it'll be interesting to try to
understand if the performance of this
generalized product formulas could be
improved using this analysis we have
been talking about error analysis but of
course if we want to use them you know
on a quantum computer we have to discuss
circuit implementation so for some
concrete systems will be interesting to
try to come up with an optimized circuit
elimination for example in quantum
chemistry we have just derived some
bounds then we numerically implement
that for two systems the nearest
neighbor systems and parallel systems
and as the system becomes more
complicated and as you choose a more
complicated for that founder the
computation of those bounds won't be
very fast and it'll be interesting to
derive some first numerical procedures
to compute those balance so that you can
get an accurate estimation of okay thank
you
well you can consider different cost
metric so for example there are some
recent work on the so called a sub
circuit model so instead of as you mean
constant cost for each elementary
exponential you can assume that the
cause of performing each elementary
exponential will depends on the duration
the time duration for example if you
want to rotate via angled and the Cosmo
depends on how large you rotate that
term so probably you can get some
improvements by switching through this
sub circuits moto and and perhaps is
more realistic and we've been talking
about simulating the dynamics and if you
have some further information about the
initial state let's say if you start
with a simple low energy initial state
there hopefully you have further speed
up your simulation by taking advantage
of that information more practical
issues such as noise probably you could
study the simulation the
that's nice and there could be also
other applications in other areas and
with that we have you know a happy end
you'll see a story and sex for listen so
we have time for questions so you can
ask questions in the chat or you can
unmute just answer
okay let me ask a question from Renaud
you don't want to unmute yourself I can
also ask it myself if you prefer I mean
that good yeah if you can't that's
easier so there's a very nice talk you
want Thanks
so my question is about the dependence
on the error epsilon one of the good
things in qubit ization and these other
methods is that this is only like a
loved one over epsilon defenders yeah
certainly cinema style Trotter is more
like one over epsilon dependence you
sort of suppress a dependence on epsilon
I think so could you say if there are
fancier product formulas that get a
logarithmic dependence on the air yeah
indeed the other reason work by some of
the people from Microsoft a group they
have developed so called multi product
formula algorithm so it's actually it's
an LCU construction these two here so
your idea is to take a linear
combination of product flow meters and
try to implement that on a quantum
computer and it turns out that if you
choose the linear combination to be you
choose a linear combination very
carefully you can implement a product
from another simulation with logarithmic
dependence
however absolute and but as far as I
know we are not able to apply our
analysis to analyzing that product
vomiter in a satisfied way so that'll be
an interesting question to explore so in
practice in practical applications
usually what people do is they usually
fix
certain accuracy in the simulation if
they choose a currency to be ten to the
minus three and do the simulations so in
this case the error dependents will only
kicks in as a constant prefactor so
whether one quantum algorithm is
advantageous will depends on the
constant pre-factor and yeah a question
along a similar line spirit that runner
just asked me and this is really
beautiful work and I like it a lot
especially since you you you did this
also with the singular value transform
work and my question is relating to that
so as Ronald has pointed out there's
still some advantages to things like
qubit ization signal processing and
singular value transform in fact and so
I'm curious now that you have gone
through all of this readjustment of the
trader ization what do you think about
the relative benefits of the singular
value transform approach versus this
approach especially given that singular
very transform can take into account
what you're trying to measure and not
just what you're trying to simulate the
hamiltonian yes that's a very good
question so for example in some of the
applications in quantum chemistry the
goal is not to try to simulate the
evolution of the Hamiltonian but rather
try to estimate that's at the ground
state energy and in this case for
example I guess one thing that you can
do is you do a phase estimation and in
this case it turns out that you don't
need to simulate the flow dynamics for
example you can use like your qubit
ization approach and in this approach
you implements some functions of the
Hamiltonian like the arc cosine or sine
and you can do some classical
post-processing on that function and you
don't have to apply the singular value
transformation or signal processing and
that could be a place where the qubit
ization approach could be advantages
over other approaches
so so if you were if you were a graduate
student for the next six years that you
are supervising because you have trained
finished would you would you continue
working on trotter ization or would you
work on something more sophisticated
like what Ronald and I are thinking
about well I'm happy to work on both
directions but I guess the point is if
we want to care about the practical
applications of quantum simulations and
we always have to choose the fastest
quantum simulation algorithm and so I
guess that for previous picture here so
here we have from some results for
simulating the one-dimensional
Heisenberg model and we compares arcade
complexity and for this system there are
a lot of locality properties that you
can use so it seems that product founder
is the best one but maybe for some other
systems perhaps as approaches would be
the best one and and also if you change
what you're measuring at the end yeah
yeah exactly so I guess my personal
opinion is that there's like no
universal way of identifying a like the
best quantum simulation algorithm it
largely depends on the system that you
are simulating me thank you
Thanks and ask another question about
this picture
sure ask the question for go ahead go
ahead okay thanks yes so it's about this
picture that's almost light right now so
it seems that that not only is the the
empirical performance of the product
formula straight down which because this
is a log scale means constant
improvement like a much better Big O but
also the slope seems to be better said
right yes so so here's a general form of
this kind of nearest neighbor in taxes
system and
so each other that the product vomiter
as we are able to show is has this kind
of complexity virgins miracles -
intensity and if you just naively use a
cubit hesitation approach you will have
something like N squared times T I think
so that N squared times T will be larger
than this n times T if you choose
appropriate product formula so that
probably explains why the slope of the
product formula will be smaller than the
other approaches so there are some
algorithm developed by how Hastings
coherent loads it applies as lead
robinson based approach and you can't
combine that approach with cubit ization
together near the optimal simulation so
that can also help given the terrible
constant in a big or not not necessarily
terrible but my personal takeaway is
that the product vomiter is do what
about hatreds for significant business
good thanks so two questions first of
all think for the very nice talk the
first one follows the previous volume of
questions which is related to quantum
cinema processing in the quantum the
singular value transformation another
putative you did and well for the
quantum signal processing everything the
circuit is very good the only trouble
maker is really the block including
right here so do you think there are
matrices that are inherently much easier
to construct the bulk encoding but much
trickier to do the authorization oh this
is a very good question so well guess a
very common way to construct block
including some to use this linear
combination of unitary formulas on i
will turns out that in many systems in
quantum chemistry you can get a nor gate
capacities and the product formula so
usually if you
naively implement product familiar
your complexity will at least depends on
the system size of the of your helmet on
you but if you construct this linear
combination formalism let's say to
prepare and select circuits it won't
directly scale with system size boot
depends on for example you are
simulating chemistry system it depends
on the number of spin orbitals in your
system so basically you have a better
skating if you use this kind of being a
combination approach blocking code
approach does that make sense yeah yeah
so so the second question is related to
your Outlook which is said that you
wanna fast in America methods for
completing the error bounds can't be a
little more specific which is a I mean
you really don't directly compute this
balance it is for a posteriori error
justification and also dynamic change of
the step size or something like that
yeah I guess a typical way so you can do
some impurity estimation so yeah you
really do delta T TT over to you do some
other constant I mean yeah there's order
I mean like the many device that would
be the standard but here it seems we
pretty keen at computing exactly these
bounds can I know why yes so it's a just
mention a typical wave so you can try to
compute that for small systems like
seven cubic system eight qubits and you
can try to extrapolate the data to much
larger sizes and you believe that would
be the performance of product formulas
and but I don't know I guess maybe you
know other applications where we really
care about the accuracy perhaps it'll be
interesting to try to derive some some
rigorous error bounds and try to
guarantee that indeed your your results
after the simulation is achieving this
accuracy in a rigorous way
any more questions
it looks like an Rock has a question in
the chat sorry oh yeah I just follow up
on what Andrew said I'm just wondering
where that whiskey law one of Epsilon
dependents might be conceivable using
product formulas and by the way you and
very nice talk
Thanks okay repeat your question and you
mention read that to get this low moaner
epsilon in this the formalism people
have you started using LC u methods
which Endre mentioned that it requires
an sellers so is it possible that you
know you might be able to achieve long
run over epsilon dependence using non
end syllabus methods I don't know maybe
for some special systems you can't chief
okay I guess in the extreme case where
all the terms commute with each other
you don't have any error so that error
dependence is not there but my
impression is that for general systems
you will always have the polynomial
dependence on well where absolute and
maybe there's some lower bound arguments
for that but I am not sure about that
first of all some special systems you
should be able to improve that like in
the extreme case where our terms commute
but our thanks thanks
any more questions okay if there's no
more questions let's all thank you one
again for the talk
thanks John thanks very much so I wanted
to remind everyone that next week we're
having the third workshop but the
assignments for this workshop on quantum
devices organized by VDB shinzo Barbara
hull and Ignacio Seok and you can find
the workshop schedule by going to the
Symons website and there will be zoom
links there so I encourage everyone to
attend because of the workshop there
won't be a seminar next week and we'll
have probably the last seminar of the
semester week after next when Lynn Lynn
will tell us about some of his work on
quantum algorithms for you
so thanks everyone have a good Tuesday
and let me stop the recording